tu me manques tellement tu aussi m fais
attention quand tu sors de la station
[Musique]
toujours quel bonheur d'être enfin de
retour mais les choses sont
différentes
il y a un piano dans mon
salon je ne joue pas de
piano vous avez des hallucination
[Musique]
oui les astronautes vivent des choses
qu'ils ne comprennent pas certaines
personnes
perdent quand j'étais làhaut la seule
chose à laquelle je pensais c'était
rentrer auprès de ma
fille s de la station maman qui a dit ça
c'était toi et moi juste avant
l'accident c'était pas
moi où est-ce qu'elle
est
to j'ai inventé une machine que nous
avons envoyé dans l'espace je crois bien
avoir vu quelque chose mais ce quelque
chose ne veut pas être
vu les gens voient des choses
là-haut et quand ils reviennent ils
deviennent
fous tout ça ce n'est pas de la
folie il faut que tu
m'aides il faut que je la
retrouve tu trouves que je suis toujours
la
même j'ai pas l'impression que tu sois
vraiment ma
mère